self-checkout is a failed experiment
when self- checkout kiosks began to pop
up in American grocery stores the sales
pitch to Shoppers was impressive scan
your stuff plunk it in a bag and you're
done long checkout lines would disappear
weights would dwindle small talk with
cashiers would be a thing of the past
need help store associates freed from
the drudgery of scanning barcodes would
be close at hand to answer your
questions you know how this process
actually goes by now though you still
have to wait in line scanning those
items is sometimes a crapshoot wave a
barcode too vigorously in front of an
uncooperative machine and suddenly
you've scanned it two or three times
these days everyone uses self checkout
also so you end up waiting in line
behind a row of people who all have like
a hundred items in their cart and they
for some reason take a minute per item
to scan it another 15 minutes to put it
in a bag I was waiting the line behind
someone the other day that was like they
were putting each item in its own bag
and I'm not much of an environmentalist
by the but even I'm sitting there like
this is a lot of plastic that we're
wasting here this is not good I mean
even I was starting to feel bad for the
sea turtles or whatever